متفائله قائده شغافه وفضوليا اسم الله رب
وجابر من لبنان ناشطه اجتماعيه
[موسيقى]
اصبت تعود لمرحله من مراحل دراسته وقت
كانت التلميذ المثاليه كنت مثابره
المعلومات بيعرفونا وفجاه صرنا بصف السادس
وصار يعطونا صفوف مسرح
المعلم
بوقتها كثير تضايقت وضليتني فتره ما قادره
اعبر على اليسار معك
الايام لشركه علمي عمله وقت طبقنا البحث
العمل
هذا المشروع هو عباره عن مجموعه شباب
نجتمع لنجمع بيانات معينه ونلاقي قضيه
ناصر او نعمل مشروع المناصره مفيهاش اصلا
ناخذ تدريبات معي يعني ومن ضمن تدريبات
حول الصحه النفسيه
وبالتالي ضلينا لازم ثاني عم نشتغل عن
الصحه النفسيه كان بالاول متطوعه رجعته
وهذه السنه كانت مناسعه كمان اشتغلنا عن
الصحه النفسيه ولكن بالمجال التعليميه
عملنا مشروع المناصره مع فريق رائع بس
طبقنا المشروع بالمدارس رسميه بالمنطقه
ولو بشكل بسيط ولو بشكل معنا ويقدر نكون
حد للتنميه الزاهد الفتره وعلى الصعيد
الشخصي حسيت انه اف 9 كان حددت لميس يلي
قطعت همم ايش يعني متشابهه واقف متشابهها
دلوقت يعني ما كان في حاجه احد فيها يعني
وبالتالي اخذت هذه القضيه ااا حبيت فكره
الصحه النفسيه ولقيت انه ضروري نكون عمل
ناصر فيها وحاول اهميه هذا الموضوع خصوصي
انه بعض المجتمعات بعده بيعتبروا انه
تابوه
شخصيتي ابدا ما كانت هيك كان شخص كثير
بستحي اا منو ابدا يعني هيك شخص انت واقف
ما كنت
ولا متطوعه ولا شيء بس بدعم اكيد من اهلي
على عمر كثير صغير على عمر اربع سنين همم
اتطوعت بالكشاف وهمم فرصه ولا فرصه فرصه
ولا فرصه لا فرصه لها
همم مع الوقت والخبره همم بتزيد الثقه
بالنفس
وبنعمل اكثر من قدراتنا وصلنا نعمل الفكره
ونطبق شيء معي بلا ما يكون في برده
الحلقه همم
همم يمكن همم حلم بتحقق احلام ما بيتحقق
حلم ما بيتحقق همم باحس انه بتمنى اقدر
يكون عم بيحمل يمكن اوجاع الناس او اقدر
اساعدهم بعرف يمكن صعبه شوي بس حدا عن حدا
قريب ااه بس حلم الاساسي والكبير يمكن ان
نخلص دراستك وبدايتان ونصير طبيعي ان شاء
الله وهمم اكيد ظلني بطاقه الموجوده فيه
الهدف الاساسي اكيد همم
راحه البال وبس يمكن لو حد اقل من ثلاث
اربع سنين انه لارا انت بهذا المرحله
وقت صيامده وفعلا هيمضي بحل هو بمره فاذا
قطعته بظروف صعبه اعطوه
اعتبروه درس وقطع لانه اكيد بعدين هيثمروا
باشياء كثير حلوه
[موسيقى]